profesor adrián baranchuk muchas gracias
por estar con nosotros aquí en radio
canadá internacional usted en uno de sus
estudios hizo referencia a la relación
entre el 19 y las lesiones del miocardio
q decirnos por favor de qué se trata
esto muchísimas gracias luis por la
invitación a estar con ustedes hoy
específicamente se publicaron diversos
estudios que muestran la relación entre
la infección por e.coli 19 y las
lesiones cardíacas lo primero que me
gustaría clarificar louis es que esto no
es un predominio de kobe
19 sino que las enfermedades virales en
forma general y las enfermedades
infecciosas de manera más global pueden
afectar la función cardíaca la normal
contracción del músculo cardíaco y la
conducción eléctrica en el corazón
porque entonces llegamos a un nivel de
relevancia tan importante respecto de la
relación joven 19 y corazón simplemente
porque en el medio de una pandemia que
no ha tenido precedentes para todos los
que estamos vivos en este momento el
estudio de los pacientes con kobe es
muchísimo más extenso que por ejemplo el
de los pacientes con influenza o con el
él o el de los pacientes con infecciones
por bacterias estamos tan concentrados
en el estudio y el impacto que el coach
produce en los diferentes órganos del
cuerpo que ahora tenemos muchísima más
información que lo que hemos tenido
antes lo que no necesariamente significa
que el código tiene una predilección por
el corazón por encima de otros carnes
la enorme atención que ha merecido como
usted decía el tema de la pandemia ha
incluido además entre otras
informaciones la presunta relación entre
el com y 19 trastornos cardíacos por lo
que usted viene de decirnos que esto no
sería tan así bueno que me gustaría
clarificar este punto esta es una
excelente pregunta la lesión cardíaca
por kobe si existe y aparte de existir
indica peor pronóstico para el paciente
si en vez de hablar del corazón louis
por ejemplo hablamos del sistema
cardiovascular en general que involucra
las venas y las arterias si los
pacientes se produce se presentan con
trombosis
en las en los vasos de los pulmones
estos pacientes tienen peor pronóstico y
mayor mortalidad
entonces contestando su pregunta es si
las lesiones cardiovasculares existen y
son graves e indican en la evolución de
impacientes con cover que el paciente
puede requerir más uso de intubación y
ventilación artificial y por el otro
lado un peor pronóstico y mayor
mortalidad todos los pacientes que vemos
internados graves con kobe se mueren
fundamentalmente por dos causas
una es la falla pulmonar irreversible y
segundo es el compromiso cardiovascular
ahora
es esto un estigma del cob y todavía no
lo sabemos porque para eso habría que
comparar la misma cantidad de pacientes
con la misma intensidad de estudios en
otras afecciones virósicas y eso se ha
hecho pero mucho más parcialmente no es
que no sabemos nada de por ejemplo
-insisto influenza y corazón sabemos
mucho sabemos por ejemplo que la
vacunación contra influenza previene el
deterioro de las enfermedades
cardiovasculares sin embargo esta
avalancha de información que tenemos en
común no la tenemos en otras
enfermedades entonces por un lado si
existe y son pacientes del peor
pronóstico pero por el otro lado no
quiere decir que las complicaciones
cardiovasculares del joven sean
específicas del joven sino que podrían
ser generales a todas las infecciones
que afectan de manera sistémica el
organismo por lo que usted dice además
el hecho de que kobe
además preferentemente digámoslo de esta
manera al sistema respiratorio también
complicaría el tratamiento de los
pacientes que tengan problemas
coronarios
absoluto y ahí usted está identificando
lo que se llama una población de riesgo
en pacientes con hipertensión arterial
con diabetes o con enfermedad cardíaca
en el caso de lo que usted menciona la
enfermedad de las arterias coronarias
preexistentes son considerados
individuos de alto riesgo en el caso de
contraer con por eso las estrategias en
salud pública deben dirigirse a proteger
específicamente los pacientes con estas
condiciones preexistentes porque sabemos
que de contraer el cóver están en el
grupo de mayor alto riesgo me gustaría
incluir en estos tres en estas tres
categorías una cuarta que sería obesidad
todos los factores de riesgo
cardiovascular
ponen a estos individuos en alto riesgo
en el caso de contraer cover en alto
riesgo de tener una peor evolución por
favor y para su audiencia que es muy
amplia esto no significa que todo
paciente con alguna de estas cuatro
características vaya a tener una mala
evolución significa que si comparo
individuos del mismo sexo y de
relativamente la misma edad sin estos
factores de riesgo los que lo tienen
tienen una evolución más torpe y de una
evolución peor pero no significa que
todos ellos vayan a ser pacientes que
terminen
presentando mortalidad doctor gancho
perdón
en uno de los muchísimos estudios en los
que ustedes han participado usted y sus
colegas han hecho referencia además a la
importancia del electrocardiograma como
una de las herramientas más útiles en el
tratamiento de los pacientes no solo con
comida con otras dolencias pero en el
caso específico en el que estamos
tratando ahora también del cómic 19 por
qué por qué es tan importante y por qué
es tan útil en todo caso el
electrocardiograma y gracias por esta
pregunta louis el grupo que publicó la
revisión más extensa en el valor del
electrocardiograma surge de un grupo de
jóvenes investigadores de la
international site de fe electro
cardiology que tuve el placer de
presidir hasta el año pasado
y en esta sociedad creamos un grupo de
jóvenes investigadores que son
monitoreados y supervisados por
investigadores expertos y hay gente de
canadá de eeuu de españa de argentina de
colombia de hong kong de australia
en este caso este proyecto fue liderado
por un joven de 22 23 años
racing
canadiense que se encuentra actualmente
estudiando medicina en australia o sea
son gente que están en la veintena y en
la treintena lo cual me produce mucha
alegría ver jóvenes involucrándose de
lleno en investigación cardiovascular y
en este caso en las manifestaciones del
cobre en el director cardiograma como
usted señaló el electrocardiograma es un
método de evaluación cardiaca no
solamente muy económico sale un dólar o
dos dólares producir un
electrocardiograma sino que es muy fácil
de ser transmitido digitalmente a la
distancia entonces hoy tenemos pacientes
que están en nigeria que se puede
conectar un electrocardiograma
transmitirlo inmediatamente a canadá
proveer una opinión y ayudar a colegas
que están en áreas remotas del mundo a
estar conectados digitalmente y poder
brindarle el mejor cuidado a sus
pacientes y resulta hacer que el
electrocardiograma como así también una
sustancia que libera el corazón
troponina que nos dice que el corazón
está sufriendo la combinación de estos
dos factores esta sustancia que libera
el corazón que se detecta en una muestra
de sangre y el electrocardiograma que es
el registro de la actividad eléctrica en
la superficie del tórax nos permiten
determinar si un paciente con kobe está
yendo hacia el grupo de pacientes que
presentan alteraciones cardiovasculares
y como le decía al principio esos son
los pacientes que parecieran tener la
peor evolución entonces fíjese con dos
elementos muy sencillos uno podría decir
aunque este paciente todavía no tenga
falta de aire este paciente pareciera
ser que va evolucionando hacia peor así
que lo voy a admitir tal vez no en
terapia intensiva tal vez en una sala
común tal vez en una terapia intermedia
pero lo voy a monitorear más
extensamente porque este paciente tiene
chances de tener compromiso cardíaco y
peor evolución doctor aunque no es parte
de su área específica de acción
investigación en un artículo
periodístico usted hizo referencia a lo
que se conoce como niebla mental que es
uno de los síntomas que sienten los
pacientes del cómic 19 puede decirnos
sintéticamente a qué se refiere qué
quiere decir estos niños lamentan
muchas gracias esto es una nota que ha
levantado un periodista científico que
admiro mucho que se llama pablo esteban
que me invitó a dar una perspectiva como
usted bien dice por fuera de lo que es
la especialidad
para analizar el fenómeno desde un punto
de vista científico en forma anecdótica
y esto es importante luis creo que se lo
explicamos a la audiencia una cosa son
estudios en grandes poblaciones
comparando una población enferma contra
una población menos enferma o una
población enferma recibiendo la droga
contra placebo ellos son estudios
que ayudan a guiar la práctica en este
caso estos fueron los reportes
anecdóticos de pacientes que luego de
haber tenido un cómic grave y haber
pasado por ejemplo por terapia intensiva
algunos de ellos haber sido incubados y
haberse recuperado
en su vida post post cover de repente
tienen fogonazos donde tienen pérdida de
lo que se llama la memoria inmediata hay
un caso muy interesante de una enfermera
entraba a una habitación habla con su
paciente da perfectas indicaciones sale
de la habitación le pregunta en que
acaba de pasar y no recuerda la
interacción es bastante impactante
sin embargo vuelvo a insistir en un
concepto cuando uno tiene o ha
atravesado un trauma físico o mental
la pérdida transitoria de la memoria
inmediata es un factor muy común no es
necesariamente asociado con corrió por
favor el mundo estampan desvió a los
médicos somos seres humanos que también
atravesamos la pandemia con las mismas
vulnerabilidades miedos dudas e
incertidumbres sobre el futuro entonces
que en algún momento no recordemos donde
dejamos las llaves del coche aunque no
recordemos cuál fue la última
conversación que tuvimos con nuestras
parejas o nuestros hijos
no es algo tan espectacularmente raro
luego de estar sumergidos en
involucrados en traumas físicos e
inventados entonces imaginemos ahora una
una persona louis que estuvo
que estuvo internado en terapia
intensiva que sabe a priori que mucha
gente que en 30 era intensiva nunca más
sale recuperada y en estos casos se
recuperaron y se reintegran a la
sociedad
aquí sociedad se reintegraron con alguna
sociedad sana optimista que los recibe
con los brazos abiertos no se integran a
una sociedad que está pasando por las
mismas calamidades que pasaron ellos sin
haber tenido el episodio traumático de
haber estado internada no podremos sin
manu cargando el estigma no cargando al
estigma de y yo no lo tuve yo creo que
esa gente tiene el derecho de tener
algún lapso de niebla mental
me explico prestemos la atención hay
estudios en curso y vamos a tener más
información seguramente puedo que me
invite a charlar nuevamente en un par de
meses puntual o podamos descentralizar
un poco más pero por ahora yo diría
seamos pacientes al kiel que ha tenido
un trauma físico mental corrido o no con
ya hablé por ejemplo con alguien que ha
pasado por un accidente automovilístico
grave
esta gente emocionalmente mentalmente
queda muy afectada
entonces yo no se sienta bien niebla
mental es necesariamente orgánica o es
un impacto en la esfera emocional tal
vez en términos sencillos podríamos
decir que se trata de parte de la del
estrés de la experiencia estresante que
significa haber pasado por el comil 19
es en los personales estoy muy de
acuerdo con la forma en la que lo oculto
y lo plantea por supuesto que debemos
esperar más porque va a haber estudios
serios en esta en esta área también y
posiblemente dentro de dos o tres meses
sea como demos nuestro discurso con los
datos que tenemos son muchas veces veo
gente criticando pero el ministro dijo
en marzo que
los señores entre marzo y octubre hemos
aprendido tanto que muchas veces los
mismos científicos hemos reacomodado
nuestro discurso a medida que la
información está disponible no creo que
sea justo evaluar lo que alguien dijo en
marzo porque yo mismo aceptó haber ido
cambiando alguna de las perspectivas
mediante el aprendizaje rápido y
acelerado de esta enfermedad a medida
que la información estuvo disponible
doctor baranchuk y muchas gracias por
esta entrevista con radio canadá
internacional y por supuesto quedábamos
en contacto para un para una entrevista
a futuro que de mi parte con todo gusto
llevaremos a cabo muchísimas gracias
luis por esta invitación y quedó a total
de exposición de radio internacional
canadá